how's it going everyone this is Daniel
from the chess website and Welcome to
our video today we are going to be
discussing the three nights game not to
be confused with the four nights game
the three nights game occurs after the
following moves white plays E4 black
plays E5 white plays Knight F3 black
plays Knight C6 so far pretty normal I'm
sure you've seen this Millions well not
millions of times but many times and
after the move Knight C3
black can play the move Knight F6 and
make it a for Knights game however the
purpose of this video will be looking at
the three nights game which is
characterized by basically any
reasonable move that black can play
other than to move Knight F6 now why
might black not want to play Knight F6
it is the most common move and the most
theoretical you know Grand Masters play
it I even play it myself so why might
people maybe try to avoid it well the
thing is these positions are extremely
symmetrical and sometimes they can get
dry like an example line might be you
know this position white might go D4 and
basically transpose to a four Knight
scotch and I mean I don't mind these
positions for either side it could get
sharp in some certain situations but it
can also just get pretty dry after moves
like you know Bishop B4 just like takes
takes and then Bishop D3 you just kind
of see there's not a lot going on maybe
relative to other types of openings so
the reason why players might avoid the
Four Knights is to get a little bit more
in Balance so one example is if black
will start with if black develops the
bishop either to B4 or to C5 if Black
Goes Bishop B4 you can do a number of
different things you could probably just
develop the bishop you could maybe just
play Pawn to A3 just see what they want
to do there's there's not really a lot
of bad options you can play here but the
most common move in this position is
this move Knight D5 You're simply going
after the bishop and it's pretty well
known especially the higher level you
get if they just let you get the bishop
pair in the opening you should generally
take it and say something like C3 and
like D3 something like this long term
generally especially in a position that
could open up having the two Bishops can
be very advantageous so normally black
will just move the bishop away Bishop A5
is the most common way to do so just
sort of maybe keep keeping this pressure
on the diagonal maybe keeping the option
open of going here someday and
pressuring F2 and the main line here
goes Bishop C4 Knight F6 and so black
proposes sort of a trade of knights or
at least initiates that contact we don't
have to do anything about we can just
castle and it's worth noting now I
didn't check this but I believe after
Knight takes D5 yes we can just play e
takes D5 and we're attacking the Knight
and we're also we also have an eye on
this Pawn so clearly it would be pretty
good if they release the tension first
and importantly if they were to take
this Freel looking pawn it might seem
like oh there's just a pawn hanging like
what do we do about this well we can
just play this move d4 and just sort of
crack open the position
the point is we're attacking the E5 pawn
and if black just takes we have this
move Queen E2 to pin the Knight and
there's not really going to be a great
way for black to get out of this like I
mean they can play F5 but I mean they've
weakened their King side I imagine
Knight G5 is probably just winning um
you just I mean they like ideas like
this although I guess they can block
with G6 but you can just take and like
again they played F5 so you can't even
Castle cuz there's this lineup so I
would not worry too much about that pawn
in this specific line so another option
for black is to go Bishop C5 so maybe
you're delaying the development of your
knight but putting the bishop on C5
first just to see how things go and this
is not bad but you actually have a minor
tactical shot in this position it's very
thematic in these e45 openings where
there's like a bishop developed and like
a Pawn on E5 that you can take Knight
takes E5 and the idea is that after
Knight takes E5 it might seem like for a
second well I just lost my knight for a
pawn like what's my idea here well it's
pretty clear you just go D4 here and
you're just going to win a piece
back and white does very well in these
positions after Bishop D6 D takes E5
Bishop takes E5 here the move Bishop D3
is good because maybe in some positions
the E4 Pawn could be attacked your
long-term plan s of is to go like F4 and
then gain space so the main line goes
Knight F6 castles castles and then after
F4 black can play Bishop D4 check but
we're not that worried we just go King
H1 and you know you're longterm you're
just going to play like Bishop D2 maybe
Knight E2 to kick away the bishop and
then possibly try to do something with
this majority and I'm not claiming that
you're completely winning or anything
like that but you have a very
comfortable Advantage I would say so
that's Bishop B4 and Bishop C5 from
those positions another option is for
Black to play D6 but I would just say
you have a pretty easy game if you just
go D4 and after D4 black can go Bishop
G4 for instance I mean if they take you
can just take back and if they ever take
you just take with your queen and your
Queen's not really going anywhere you
have a very comfortable position here
and if they just develop with their
Knight I mean the game will go on I
imagine the theory is probably like
maybe takes and Bishop C4 for instance
or even like Bishop C4 immediately and I
mean you'll just notice that long term
all of your pieces are active whereas a
lot of Black's pieces are active but
there's a glaring hole in their
development which is that their this
bishop will not be able to get out
effectively so I would say if your
opponent plays D6 again all these
specific moves you don't have to
necessarily worry about oh yeah for the
record I believe the main line is D4
Bishop G4 and then you can just play
this bishop B5 move here the point being
you're threatening this D5 move which
attacks the pinned Knight and so black
will normally take and you can kind of
flex on your opponent by playing Queen
takes D4 oh no my queen well not quite
so anywh who and then you're just going
to like develop your bishop move your
queen away if you need to maybe Castle
along and again you just have a very
comfortable position that's what the
three nights game is about you're not
winning out the opening necessarily but
you're getting very playable comfortable
positions to where you can put your
pieces on good squares and outplay and
potentially beat your opponents from
there so those were some options another
option that black can try is this move
G6 G6 I believe I think Bishop B4 is the
most common but I think G6 is close up
there among like master level play the
idea obviously being to go Bishop G7 and
sort of imbalance the game that way here
White's best move again you can't really
go wrong with just developing the bishop
or something like that but the most
challenging move in these positions are
to play
D4 and after D4 what you'll note in a
lot of these like Scotch likee positions
I imagine there are videos on the chess
website about the scotch defense or the
scotch opening is that so the scotch and
just sort of show you the theme is E4 E5
Knight F3 Knight C6 D4 so you have this
structure to where you have the two
Pawns in the center you're challenging
them with the pawn on D4 and they only
have one Pawn black almost has to take
like theoretically they must take the
pawn if they neglect to take the pawn
then you can just well first of all
you're threatening to win a pawn so you
could just do that but if they even just
play Move Like D6 then you can just
positionally steamroll them with a move
like D5 and even I'm not saying this is
the best line but even if you play
something like this you just have a very
good position just out of the opening
you have firm control of the center your
opponent is cramped and uh yeah so it's
pretty well known that from these
positions we're looking at uh G6 after
G6 D4 that black really should take and
if they don't take you can expect to
either be able to push or maybe take the
Pawn for free so after D4 black just
goes ahead and takes and actually the
variation I'm about to show you is
technically an opening trap so I'm going
to rewind and I would definitely pay
attention and maybe take notes if you
want new opening trap to add to your
Arsenal so once again the moves are E4
E5 Knight F3 Knight C6 Knight C3 if
black plays the move
G6 here we go D4
and after e takes
D4 we can play Knight takes D4 and there
are some good positions that you can get
from there certainly you can play it
sort of aggressively almost like an open
Sicilian if they play the dragon but
here this move Knight D5 is interesting
so what's the point behind Knight D5
well you're sort of controlling some key
squares and it's kind of apparent so
Black's most natural move by far is
going to be Bishop G7 anyway you know
maybe practically they'll see that like
oh the Knight is uh Knight's in my
territory I got to do something I
actually just noticed they go Knight E7
you have Checkmate that's funny uh if
they go Knight F6 and I imagine you just
play this move Bishop G5 which sort of
comes up here in a minute uh so after
Knight to D5 black will normally just go
Bishop G7 anyway they're sort of
incentivized to do so anyway to protect
the pawn and here we play the move
Bishop G5 after Bishop to G5
so you're attacking the queen and you
sort of see the knight's power on the D5
Square in that you're controlling a lot
of potential blockade squares black has
to know the move Knight C to E7 if they
play the move Knight C to E7 which does
undefended Pawn by the way you just take
and then you have a pretty good game
however I imagine that most players at
your level they will probably go Knight
G to E 7 or they might go Knight F6
which Knight F6 just fails to E5 which
pins and wins the Knight so Knight F6 is
a blunder and Knight to E7 Knight G to
E7 that is is a blunder also for a
little bit of a less obvious reason the
reason being even though this pawn it
looks like it's protected twice and only
attack twice you can still take it you
can play this move Knight takes D4
and the point is after Knight takes D4
if they're to take back with the Knight
well the Knight has lost protection of
its friend on E7 so you can just take on
E7 the queen is trapped uh you're just
going to win a queen out of it and you
just have a very good winning position
here if black plays the move Bishop
takes D4 and just thinks well nothing
bad is happening everything's protected
and I'm just going to be up a piece not
so fast you play This brilliant
sacrifice Queen takes D4 the idea behind
Queen takes D4 is if the queen is taken
then you have a checkm in two turns here
so if you want to find a little exercise
I will invite you to pause the video if
you've done a lot of your tactics and I
imagine you'll see this very quickly but
in this position you just have move
Knight F6 the king is forced to the f8
square and then this bishop H6 move is
checkmate with the Knight and the bishop
so just to sort of Rego over that
opening trap so I know you all love
opening traps and uh I'm happy to add
one to Your Arsenal potentially it's E4
E5 Knight F3 Knight C6 Knight C3 black
goes for his move G6 we play this move
d4 then after e takes D4 we don't quite
capture on D4 we go Knight D5 black goes
Bishop G7 we go Bishop G5 Black Goes
Knight G to E7 if Knight F6 they lose a
piece so black will try Knight G to E7
and then here we go Knight takes D4
Bishop takes Queen takes Knight takes
check King f8 and then
Checkmate well I think that's a good way
to end the video if you need to review
the lines again always feel free to just
re-watch the video there are a lot of
lines there and just a lot of
conclusions to where you just have a
very comfortable position but I would
say if you have the white side overall
and your opponent doesn't go into the
Four Knights then you just you should
just have a very good Advantage
potentially out of the opening but I
would definitely have something ready
for in case they do go over the four
nights so thank you so much for watching
this is Daniel from the chess website
and I'll see you for the next video take
care